[Music]
it's a fascinating story what you did
because essentially you broke the rules
you snuck into Coachella and you've had
this amazing career blossom it's a lot
of people's fantasy you know that I
could just break in somewhere or sneak
in somewhere and it could change my
whole life around it really worked for
you yeah somehow someway I'm sitting I'm
killing right now you're not sitting on
Conan your honor that's for later
you gotta pay the price man
settle down gang you sneak into
Coachella at 2010 and initially you did
it primarily because of a girl is that
right kinda I really wanted to hear the
music and I love these bands that were
playing so much and there happened to be
this girl that was really into is gonna
be there so it's kind of like a cherry
on top it was like I had to get there
cuz right which is good because there's
always a it's it's that's a real
motivating factor if there's a girl you
want to impress or see you use cameras
as props that was key to we just saw
that clip to getting you through the
gates yeah I've used so many fun ways to
get into into festivals one of those
ways is using cameras of prop walking
and talking like you're a Press
photographer and and just trying to play
it off like you're meant to be there
right because what it is is they quickly
they see so many press people with
cameras that that initially just helped
you get by and then you actually took
some photographs and here's the thing
that I think separates you you didn't
just use them as props you started
taking photographs the cameras worked
obviously and you took some amazing
shots you got this shot of jay-z and it
got you a lot of attention you actually
did you you this get this portal photo
published is that right well yeah
someone on Facebook who was an intern at
Bonnaroo saw it and gave to the boss and
they reached out to me saying could we
use this photo as promotional or
something I nodi what they're gonna use
it for right and then and then that led
me to hitchhike out to Bonnaroo and and
ended up having to sneak into Bonnaroo
as well wait
at what point did you sneak in here
today or were you invited
hey but it seems like you're taking
really good photographs you're getting
known for it and you're you're actually
known for documenting things well so at
some point you're gonna start really
getting invited yes yeah that did happen
I was really lucky to be invited by one
of my favorite bands to go on this crazy
train tour across the country
yeah this is what happened you get you
you fall in with Mumford & Son
mm-hmm and and you become friends with
them mm-hmm and you end up taking is
this right you took their album cover
yeah it's a photo yes athlete do we have
that album cover photo you took this
photo yeah that's him is so hard you
know I start off as a fan that love this
music so much and jumped a bunch of
fences to see it and to fast forward a
couple years of going on tour with them
to them asked me to take the album cover
that went on to you know win the Grammy
everything else like it's it's still
it's hard to believe really
you